[Música]
se me da
el 30 de noviembre de 1957 tenía siete
años
se llevaron a mi papá a las 5 de la
mañana y se acabó
no nos dejaban salir de la habitación
estábamos en nuestras camas 8 a 9 de la
mañana
todavía nada nada que volvía a las 10
y entonces mi mamá nos mandó a la ciudad
y nos dijo vayan a donde sus críos y
díganles que su papá salió esta mañana a
las seis con policías de civil
que los conocía sobre todo que los
conocía
pero que todavía no ha vuelto que si
saben algo
así que fuimos a ver a uno de mis tíos
que nos dijo no es el único se llevaron
a otros 17 a la misma hora
tal vez sea para un control
y luego y luego nada más nada
vivimos años muy difíciles sobre todo
cuando éramos niños
cuando tenía 7 años había niñas que me
decían también me pasó a mi papá lo
metieron a la cárcel
estuvo ahí cinco años yo les decía pero
todavía tienes a tu papá que se
considera aunque estuviera cinco años
diez años en la cárcel no puedes
comparar te conmigo lo que me decían a
mi papá lo mató lado a ese en la calle
sí pero tú lo viste muerto lo viste
enterrado no puedes comparar que no es
lo mismo
uno se pregunta dónde está dónde está me
da igual sé que nunca volverá me da
igual pero hacemos el duelo dónde está
durante mucho tiempo se supo que eso les
había ocurrido a miles de argelinos pero
sólo se conocía realmente a una historia
la de morrison a los militares sabían
que esos argelinos colonizados que no
eran como son europeos con conexiones de
influencia en la francia metropolitana
nadie los tendría en cuenta pasarían por
perdidas
gracias a un archivo que descubrieron
los archivos nacionales de ultramar en
tuvimos la posibilidad de investigar un
cierto número de casos
unos mil personas de las que vimos
sus familias las habían buscado en la
prefectura de argel que fueron
secuestradas por el ejército como lo ha
podido notar utilizamos el término
secuestrar que va a recetar porque no es
para nada un arresto ordinario aunque
sabe que en cualquier momento pueden
aparecer paracaidistas en la casa de uno
llevarlo a un lugar secreto hacer lo que
quieran con uno incluso torturar se supo
rápidamente que la tortura era
sistemática y asesinarlos
por ósmosis por decisión toda la
población era el objetivo potencialmente
es decir toda la población de argelia
que llamaban musulmana tenía miedo
aquí tenemos los últimos casos
documentados los últimos a los que
añadimos documentación
y nos hemos dado cuenta de que a veces
son hombres muy jóvenes el más joven el
más joven estando ahí está espera
es el más joven de todos fue secuestrado
el 14 de junio de 1957
seguimos buscando seguimos evaluando
documento por documento información por
información con el riesgo de que en
muchos casos no avanzamos en el
conocimiento preciso de cada uno
pero con la idea de que a medida que
avancemos conoceremos el desarrollo
colectivo el desarrollo para el conjunto
en algunos casos llegamos a lo que es el
conocimiento de la familia es decir
según cualquier parecido la persona
murió bajo tortura o fue asesinada su
cuerpo fue escondido o su cuerpo fue
destruido
pero eso no nos dirá lo que realmente le
importaría mucho a la familia que sería
saber exactamente dónde como que
hicieron realmente con el cuerpo de la
persona
[Música]
me llamo su amiga
esta búsqueda concierne a mi tío su au
rabia que fue secuestrado en
1958 con otras personas por el ejército
francés me conmueve mucho aunque nunca
lo conocía
porque escuché a mi papá llorar cuando
miraba el retrato de mi tío y decía
te fuiste me dejaste solo
creo que mi papá sufrió mucho después de
la independencia buscó mucho a su
hermano y cada vez que le decían que
había una fosa común en algún lugar
sobre todo en el este por el lado de
lores y todo eso lo llamaban para que
fuera a identificar los posibles restos
de su hermana no pedimos perdón ni nada
de eso eso no es importante
que nos va a aportar
lo único que pido es encontrar sus
restos
donde lo pusieron donde lo enterraron
donde lo tiraron yo que sé eso es todo
espero poder para mí decir un día
y
logré averiguar dónde está mi tío dónde
está enterrado
y si no se lo transmitiré a mis hijos a
mis sobrinos
y tal vez algún día tomen el relevo pero
al menos habré avanzado lo mejor que
pude
[Música]